the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
we're starting a new unit today and so
this is unit two and it's called
applications of differentiation okay so
the first application and we're going to
do to today is what are known as linear
approximations whoops that should have
two peas in it approximations so that
can be summarized with one formula but
it's going to take us at least half an
hour to explain how this formula is used
so here's the formula it's f of X is
approximately equal to its value at a
base point plus the derivative times X
minus x0 all right so this is the main
formula for right now put it in a box
and let me just describe what it means
first and then I'll describe what it
means again and several other times so
first of all what it means is that if
you have a curve which is y equals f of
X it's approximately the same as its
tangent line so this other side
is the equation of the tangent line
so let's give an example I'm going to
take the function f of X which is log X
and then its derivative is 1 over X and
so let's take the base point x0 is equal
to 1 that's pretty much the only place
where we know the logarithm for sure and
so what we plug in here now are the
values so f of 1 is the log of 0 or
sorry the log of 1 which is 0 and F
prime of 1 well that's 1 over 1 which is
1 all right so now we have an
approximation formula which if I copy
down what's right up here it's going to
be log X is approximately so f of 0 is
is 0 right plus 1 times X minus 1 all
right so I plugged in here for X 0 3
places I've evaluated the coefficients
and this is the dependent variable so so
all told if you like what I have here is
that the logarithm of X is approximately
X minus 1 and let me draw a picture of
this so here's the graph of log X and
then I'll draw in the tangent line at
the place that we're considering which
is x equals 1 so here's the tangent line
all right I separated a little bit but
really I probably should have drawn it a
little closer there to show you the
whole point is that these two are nearby
but they're not nearby everywhere so
this is this is the line y equals x
minus 1
right that's the tangent line they're
nearby only when X is near one so say in
this little realm here so when X is
approximately one this is true once you
get a little farther away this straight
line the straight green line will
separate from the graph but near this
place they're close together all right
so the idea again is that the curve the
curved line is approximately the tangent
line and this is one example of it
all right so I want to explain this in
in one more way and then we want to
discuss it systematically so the second
way that I want to describe this
requires me to remind you what the
definition of the derivative is so the
definition of a derivative is that it's
the limit as Delta X goes to 0 of Delta
F over Delta X that's one way of writing
it all right and this is the way we
defined it and one of the things that we
did in the first unit was we looked at
this backwards
we used the derivative knowing the
derivatives of functions to evaluate
some limits so you were supposed to do
that on your hour test there were some
examples they are at least one example
where that was the easiest way to do the
problem so in other words you can read
this equation both ways this is really
of course the same equation written
twice now what's new about what we're
going to do now is that we're going to
take this expression here Delta F over
Delta X and we're going to say well when
Delta X is fairly near zero this
expression is going to be fairly close
to the limiting value so this is
approximately F prime of X 0 all right
so that I claim is the same as what's in
the box in pink that I have over here
all right so this
equate this approximation formula here
is the same as this one this is an
average rate of change and this is an
infinitesimal rate of change and they're
nearly the same that's the claim so
you'll have various exercises in which
this approximation is the useful one to
to use and I will as I said I'll be
illustrating this a little bit today now
let me just explain why those two
formulas in the boxes are the same all
right so let's just start over here and
explain that so that the smaller box is
the same thing if I multiply through by
Delta X as Delta F is approximately F
prime of X 0 Delta X all right and now
if I just write out what this is it's f
of X right
minus f of X 0 I'm going to write it
this way which is approximately F prime
of X 0 and this is X minus X 0 so here
I'm using the notations Delta X as X
minus x0 and so this is the change in F
this is just rewriting what Delta X is
and now the only the last step is just
to put the constant on the other side so
f of X is approximately f of x0 plus F
prime of X X minus x0 so this is this
this is exactly what I had in them just
to begin with right so these two are
just algebraically the same statement
there's one went one other way of
looking at it
all right so now I want to I want to go
through some systematic discussion here
of several linear approximations which
you're going to be wanting to memorize
and rather than its being
hard to memorize these it's supposed to
remind you so you'll have a lot of extra
reinforcement in remembering derivatives
of all kinds so when we when we carry
out these systematic discussions it's we
want to make things absolutely as simple
as possible and so one of the things
that we do is we always use the base
point to be x0 so I'm always going to
have x0 is equal to 0 in these standard
list of formulas that I'm going to going
to use and if I put x0 equals 0 then
this formula becomes f of X a little bit
simpler to read it becomes f of X is f
of 0 plus F prime of 0 times X all right
so this is probably the form that you'll
want to remember most that's again just
the linear approximation but one always
has to remember and this is a very
important thing if this one only work
near x is 1 this approximation here
really only works when X is near x0 all
right so that's a little addition that
you need to throw in so this one works
when X is near 0 all right
you can't expect it to be true far away
the curve can go anywhere it wants when
it's far away from the point of tangency
so ok so let's work this out
let's do it for the sine function for
the cosine function and for e to the X
to begin with yeah question yeah when
does this one work well so this the
question was when does this one work
again this is when X is approximately x0
because it's actually the same as this
one over here okay and indeed that's
what's going on when we when we take
this this limiting value Delta X going
to 0 is the same Delta X small so
another way of saying it is that Delta X
is small
now exactly what we mean by small will
also be explaining but it is a matter of
to some extent of intuition as to how
much how good it is in in practical
cases people will really care about how
small it is before the approximation is
useful that's a serious issue all right
so let me carry out these approximations
for X again this is always for X near
zero all right
so all of these are going to be for X
near zero so in order to make this
computation I have to evaluate the
function it's right I need to plug in
two numbers here in order to get this
expression I need to know what F of zero
is I need to know what F prime of zero
is if this is the function f of X then
I'm going to make a little table over to
the right here with F Prime and then I'm
going to evaluate F of zero and then I'm
going to evaluate F prime of zero and
then read off what the answers are right
so first of all if the function is sine
X the derivative is cosine X the value
of F at zero that sine of zero is zero
the derivative is cosine cosine of zero
is one so there we go so now we have the
coefficients zero and one so this number
is zero and this number is one so what
we get here is zero plus one times X so
this is approximately X all right
there's the linear approximation to sine
X similarly so now this is a routine
matter to just read this off with this
table
we'll do it for the cosine function if
you differentiate the cosine what you
get is negative sine X all right the
value at 0 is 1 so that's cosine of 0 at
1 the value of this minus sign at 0 is 0
so this is going back over here 1 plus 0
times X so this is
approximately 1 this linear function
happens to be constant and finally if I
do e to the X its derivative is again e
to the X and its value at 0 is 1 the
value of the derivative at 0 is also 1
so both of the terms here f of 0 and F
prime of 0 they're both 1 and we get 1
plus X all right so these are the linear
approximations you can memorize these
you'll probably remember them either
this way or that way this collection of
information here encodes the same
collection of information as we have
over here for the values of the function
and the values of their derivatives at 0
so let me just emphasize again the
geometric point of view by drawing
pictures of these results so first of
all for the sine function here's this
whoop here's the sine well close enough
okay so that's boy now that is quite
some sign isn't it let's try to make the
two bumps be the same height roughly
speaking all right
anyway the tangent line we're talking
about is here and this is y equals x and
this is the function sine X and near
zero those things coincide pretty
closely the cosine function I'll put
that underneath I guess I think I can
fit it make it a little smaller here all
right so for the cosine function we're
up here it's y equals 1 well no wonder
the tangent line is constant it's
horizontal all right the tangent line is
horizontal so the function corresponding
is constant so this is y equals cosine X
all right
and finally if I draw y equals e to the
X that's coming down like this and the
tangent line is here and it's y it is 1
plus X the value is 1 and the slope is 1
all right so this is how to remember it
graphically if you like this analytic
picture is extremely important and will
help you to deal with sines cosines and
Exponential's yeah question the question
is what do you normally use linear
approximations for good question we're
getting there first we're getting a
little library of them and I'll give you
a few examples ok so now I need to
finish the catalog with two more
examples which are just a little bit
slightly more challenging and a little
bit less obvious so the next couple that
we're going to do our log of 1 plus X
and 1 plus X to the power R ok these are
the last two that we're going to write
down and that you need to think about
now the procedure is the same as over
here namely I have to write down F prime
and I have to write down F of zero I
have to wrap write down F prime of zero
and then I'll have the coefficients to
be able to fill in what the
approximation is so f prime is 1 over 1
plus X in the case of the logarithm and
F of 0 if I plug in that's that's log of
1 which is 0 and F prime if I plug in 0
here I get 1 and similarly if I do it
for this one I get R 1 plus X to the R
minus 1 and when I plug in F of 0 I get
1 to the R which is 1
and here I get R times one to the R
minus one which is R alright so so the
corresponding statement here is that log
1 plus X is approximately X and 1 plus X
to the R is approximately 1 plus R X all
right
that's 0 plus 1 times X and here we have
1 plus R times X and now I do want to
make a connection may explain to you
what's going on here
and the connection with the first
example we already did the logarithm
once let's just point out that these are
two computations are the same or
practically the same here I use the base
point 1 but because of my sort of
convenient form which will end up being
much more convenient for pretty much
every purpose we want to do these things
near X is approximately 0 all right
you cannot expand a logarithm and
understand a tangent line for it at x
equals 0 because it goes down to minus
infinity similarly if you try to graph 1
plus x to the R or X to the our without
the 1 here
you'll discover that sometimes the slope
is infinite and so forth so this is a
bad choice of point 1 is a much better
choice of a place to expand around and
then we shift things so that it looks
like it's x equals 0 by shifting by the
1 so the connection with with the
previous example is that the what we
wrote before I could write as the
logarithm of U is U minus 1 right that's
just recopy except with the letter U
rather than the letter X and then I plug
in U is equal to 1 plus X and then that
if I copy it down you see that I have a
u in place of 1 plus X that's the same
as this and if I write out u minus 1 if
I subtract 1 from you that means that
it's
X so that's what's on the right hand
side so these are the same computation I
just changed the the variable alright so
now I want to try to address the
question that was that was asked about
how this is used and what the importance
is and what I'm going to do is is just
give you one example here and then try
to emphasize the first way in which this
is a useful idea so so or maybe this is
the second example you like so we'll
call this example two maybe CT or
anything so let's just take the
logarithm of one point one just second
let's take the logarithm of one point
one so I claim that according to our
rules
I can glance at this and I can
immediately see that it's approximately
1/10 so what did I use here
I used that the log of 1 plus X is
approximately X and the value of x that
I used was a tenth alright so that is
the formula so maybe I should put a box
around these two formulas - that's this
formula here applied with x equals 1/10
I'm claiming that 1/10 is a sufficiently
small number sufficiently close to zero
that this is an OK statement all right
now I want it so the first question that
I want to ask you is which do you think
is a more complicated thing the
left-hand side or the right-hand side I
claim that this is a more complicated
thing you'd have to go to a calculator
to punch out and figure out what this
thing is this is easy you know what 1/10
is all right
so the distinction that I want to make
is that this 1/2 this part where I'm
sorry this is hard
and this is easy alright now that may
look contradictory but I want to just do
it right above as well this is hard and
this is easy okay this looks uglier but
actually this is the hard one and this
is giving us information about it now
let me show you why that's true look
down this column here these are the hard
ones hard functions these are the easy
functions what's easier than this
nothing okay well yeah zero that's
easier but okay over here it gets even
worse these are the hard functions and
these are the easy ones all right so
that's the main advantage of linear
approximation is you get something much
simpler to deal with and if you've made
a valid approximation you can make much
progress on problems ok we'll we'll be
doing some more examples but I saw some
more questions before I made that point
yeah is this Ln of 1.1 or what
this is this is a parens live its Ln of
1.1 it's the it's the digital number
right I guess I've never used that
before a decimal point have I I don't
know okay other questions
okay so let's continue here let me give
you some more examples where it becomes
even more vivid if you like that this
approximation is is giving us something
a little simpler to deal with so here's
example three I want to find the linear
approximation near x equals zero I also
when I when I write this expression near
x equals zero that's the same thing as
this that's the same thing as saying X
is approximately zero all right of the
function e to the minus 3x divided by
square root 1 plus X all right so here's
a function ok now what I claim I want to
use for the purposes of this
approximation are just the sum of the
approximation formulas that we've
already derived all right and just to
combine them algebraically so I'm not
going to do any calculus I'm just going
to remember so with e to the minus 3x
it's pretty clear that I should be using
this formula for e to the X for the
other one it may be slightly less
obvious but we have powers of 1 plus x
over here all right so let's plug those
in I'll put this up so that you can
remember it
and we're going to carry out this
approximation so first of all I'm going
to write this so that it's slightly more
suggestive namely I'm going to write it
as a product and there you can now see
the exponent in this case R equals 1/2 a
minus 1/2 that we're going to use okay
so now I have e to the minus 3 X 1 plus
X to the minus 1/2 and that's going to
be approximately well I'm going to use
this formula I have to use it correctly
X is replaced by minus 3x so this is 1
minus 3x and then over here I can just
copy verbatim the other approximation
formula with R equals minus 1/2 so this
is x 1 minus 1/2 X all right and now I'm
going to carry out the multiplication so
this is 1 minus 3x minus 1/2 X plus 3
halves x squared
hmm okay so now here's here's our
formula so now this isn't where things
stop and indeed in this kind of
arithmetic that I'm describing now
things are actually easier than they are
in ordinary algebra and arithmetic the
reason is that there's another step
which I'm now going to perform which is
that I'm going to throw away this term
here all right I'm going to ignore it in
fact I didn't even have to work it out
because I'm going to throw it away so
the reason is that already when I pass
from this expression to this one that is
from this type of thing to this thing I
was already throwing away quadratic and
higher-order terms so this isn't the
only quadratic term there are tons of
them I have to ignore all of them if I'm
going to ignore some of them and in fact
I only want to be left with the linear
stuff because that's all I'm really
getting a valid computation for so this
is approximately 1 - so let's see it's a
total of seven halves X all right and
this is the the answer this is the
linear part so the x squared term is
negligible so we drop x squared term
terms and higher all right all those
terms should be low order if you imagine
X is a tenth or maybe a hundredth
then these terms will end up being much
smaller all right so we we have a rather
crude approach and that's really the
simplicity and that's the savings okay
so now since this unit is called
applications and these are indeed
applications to to math I also wanted to
give you a real-life application or a
place where linear approximations come
up in real life
so maybe we'll call this example for
this is supposedly a real-life example
I'll try to persuade you that it is so
so I like this example because it's got
a lot of math as well as physics in it
so here I am on the surface of the earth
and here is is a satellite going this
way at some velocity V okay and this
satellite has a clock on it because this
is a GPS satellite and it has it has a
time T okay but I have a watch fact it's
right here and I have a time which I
keep which is T prime and there's an
interesting relationship between T and T
prime which is called time dilation and
this is from special relativity and it's
the following formula T prime is equal
to T divided by the square root of 1
minus V squared over C squared where V
is the velocity of the satellite and C
is the speed of light ok so now I'd like
to get a rough idea of how different my
watch is from the clock on the satellite
all right so I'm going to use this same
approximation we've already used it once
I'm going to write T but but now let me
just remind you the situation here is we
have something of the form 1 minus u
to the minus 1/2 all right that's the
that's what's happening when I multiply
through here so with u equal to V
squared over C squared alright so so in
real life of course the expression that
you're going to use the linear
approximation on isn't necessarily its
self linear it can be any physical
quantity so in this case it's V squared
over C squared and now the approximation
formula says that this is approximately
equal to well again it's the same rule
there's an R and then X is minus u so
this is minus minus 1/2 so it's it's a 1
plus 1/2 u all right so this is
approximately by the same rule this is T
t prime is approximately T times 1 plus
1/2 V squared over C squared now I
promised you that this would be a real
life problem so the question is when
people were designing these GPS systems
they they run clocks and the satellites
you're down there you're making your
measurements you're talking to the to
the satellite bye-bye or you're
receiving it signals from it's radio the
question is is this going to cause
problems in the in the transmission and
there are there dozens of such problems
that you have to check for so in this
case what actually happens is that V is
about 4 kilometers per second that's how
fast the GPS satellites actually go in
fact they had to decide to put them at a
certain altitude and they could have
tweaked this if they put them at
different places
anyway the speed of light is 3 times 10
to the fifth kilometers per second all
right
so this number V squared over C squared
is approximately ten to the minus tenth
all right now if you actually keep track
of how much of an error that would make
in a GPS location what you would find is
maybe it's a millimeter or something
like that so in fact it doesn't matter
so that's that's nice but in fact the
engineers who are designing these
systems actually did use this very
computation exactly this and the way
that they used it was they decided that
because the clocks were different when
the satellite broadcasts its radio
frequency that frequency would be
shifted would be offset and they decided
that the fidelity was so important that
they would send the satellites off with
this kind of exactly this offset to
compensate for the way the signal is so
from the point of view of good reception
on your little GPS device they changed
the frequency at which the transmitter
in the satellites
according to exactly this rule and
incidentally the reason why they didn't
they ignored higher order terms this
sort of quadratic terms is that if you
if you take U squared that's a size 10
to the minus xx and that really is
totally negligible that doesn't matter
to any measurement at all that's on the
measure on the order of nanometers and
it's it's not important for any of the
uses to which GPS is put ok so that's a
real example of a use of linear
approximations all right so let's take a
little pause here I'm going to now
switch gears and talk about quadratic
approximations but before I do that
let's have some more questions yeah
okay so the question would have suppose
I did this by a different method all
right suppose I applied the original
formula here namely I define the
function f of X which was this function
here alright and then I plugged in its
value at x equals 0 and the value of its
derivative at x equals 0 so the answer
is yes it's also true that if I call
this function f of X then it must be
true that the linear approximation is f
of x0 plus f prime of its at zero so
it's f of x0 F prime of x0 times X right
so that should be true that's this
that's the formula that we're using it's
up there in the pink also alright so
this is the formula so now what about f
of 0 well if i plug in 0 here i get 1
times 1 so this thing is 1 so that's no
surprise
and that's what I got all right if I
computed F prime by the product rule it
would be an annoying somewhat long
computation and because of what we've
just done we know what it has to be it
has to be negative seven-halves because
this is a shortcut for doing it this is
faster than doing that but of course
that's a legal way of doing it when you
get to second derivatives you'll quickly
discover that this method that I've just
described is is complicated but far
superior to differentiating this
expression twice the would you have to
throw away an x-squared term if you
differentiate it no and in fact we
didn't really have to do that here if
you differentiate and then plug in x
equals 0 so if you differentiate this
and you plug in x equals 0 you get minus
7 halves
you've differentiate this and you plug
in x equals 0 this term still drops out
because it's just a 3x when you
differentiate and then you plug in x
equals 0 it's gone 2 and similarly if
you're up here it goes away and
similarly over here it goes away so the
higher order terms never influence the
the
this computation here this just captures
the linear features of the of the
function alright so now I want to go on
to quadratic approximation and we're now
we're going to elaborate on this formula
so a linear approximation huh well that
should have been linear approximation
liner that's interesting okay so that
that was wrong but now we're going to
change it to quadrat so suppose we we
talked about a quadratic approximation
here now the quadratic approximation is
going to be just an elaboration one more
step of detail from the linear in other
words it's an extension of the linear
approximation and so we're adding one
more term here and the extra term turns
out to be related to the second
derivative but there's a factor of two
all right so this is the formula for the
quadratic approximation and this chunk
of it of course is the linear part this
time I'll spell linear correctly all
right so the linear part is the first
piece and the quadratic part is the
second piece now I want to develop the
same catalog of functions as I as I had
before in other words I want to extend
our formulas to to the higher order
terms and if you do that for the this
example here maybe I'll even illustrate
with this example before I go on if you
do it with this example here just to
give you a flavor for what goes on
what turns out to be the case so this is
the linear version and now I'm going to
compare it to the quadratic version so
the quadratic version turns out to be
this that's what turns out to be the
quadratic approximation and when I use
this example here so this is one point
one which is the same as log of one plus
tenth right so that's approximately a
tenth minus a half one-tenth squared
right so one two hundredth so that turns
out instead of being a tenth that's
point what is it oh nine five or
something like that it's a little bit
less all right it's not point one but
it's pretty close
okay so that if you like the correction
is in the is in lower in the in the
decimal expansion all right so now let
me let me actually check a few of these
I'll carry them out and what I'm going
to probably save for next time is
explaining to you so this is why this
factor of 1/2 and we're going to do this
later
do this do this next time you can
certainly do well to stick with this
presentation for one more lecture so we
can see this reinforced all right so so
now I'm going to work out these
derivatives
of the higher order terms and let me do
it for the X approximately zero case so
so first of all I want to add in the
extra term here all right here's the
extra term for the quadratic part and
now in order to figure out what's going
on I'm going to need to compute also
second derivatives so here I need a
second derivative and I need to throw in
the value of that second derivative at 0
right so this is what I'm going to need
to compute so if I do it for example for
the sine function I already have the
linear part I need this last bit so I
differentiate the sine function twice
and I get I claim minus the sine
function the first derivative is the
cosine and the cosine derivative is the
minus the sine and when I evaluate it at
0 I get low and behold 0 sine of 0 is 0
so actually the quadratic approximation
is the same 0 times x squared there's no
x squared term here so that's why this
is such a terrific approximation it's
also the quadratic approximation for the
cosine function if you differentiate
twice you get the derivative is this
minus the sine and the derivative that
is minus the cosine all right so that's
F double Prime and now if I evaluate
that at 0 I get negative 1 and so the
term that I have to plug in here this
negative 1 is the coefficient that
appears right here so I need a minus 1/2
x squared extra alright and if you do it
for the e to the X and get an e to the X
and you get a 1 and so you get a plus
1/2 x squared here all right
now I'm going to finish these two in
just a second but I first want to tell
you about the geometric significance of
this quadratic term so here we go
geometric significance of the quadratic
term so that geometric significance is
is best to describe just by drawing a
picture here and I'm going to draw the
picture of the cosine function and
remember we already had the tangent line
so the tangent line was this horizontal
here alright and that was y equals 1 but
you can see intuitively that doesn't
even tell you whether this function is
above or below one there it doesn't tell
you much it's sort of begging for there
to be a little more information to tell
us what the function is doing nearby and
indeed that's what this second
expression does for us it's some kind of
parabola underneath here so this is y
equals 1 minus 1/2 x squared which is a
much better fit to the curve than the
horizontal line all right and this is if
you like this is the best fit parabola
so it's going to be the closest parabola
to the to the to the curve and that's
more or less the significance it's much
much closer all right I want to give you
well so I I think we'll save these other
derivations for next time because I
think we're out of time now so we'll do
these next time